am 11 juni 2015 wird dr werner
freistetter im wiener neustädter darum
zum militär bischof geweiht
der apostolische nuntius erzbischof
peter stephan zurbriggen zelebrierte den
festgottesdienst
der bischof sei wohl am kardinal
schönborn bundesminister klug
landeshauptmann pröll generalstabschef
commenda und viele andere würdenträger
bei nach der salbung des hauptes wird
dem neugeweihten bischof das evangeliar
überreicht april mitra und hirtenstab
werden ihm übergeben
werner freistetter folgt als dritter
militärbischof in österreich christian
werner
nach der bischofsstab aus rotem und
weißem holz erinnert in seinem oberen
teil an das hoheitszeichen des
österreichischen bundesheeres im rahmen
der feierlichkeit zur bischofsweihe
überreicht bundesminister klug dass
beförderungs dekret
zu ehren des neuen bischofs findet vor
dem dom ein militärischer festakt statt